[Music]
nothing but love and respect between
Tiffany Haddish and Kevin Hart two
comedians joined forces for their
upcoming film night school and only
Kevin Frazier got an exclusive invite to
that Atlanta set I wish I could my boss
won't let me hire I'll drop out Tiffany
is your teacher Tiffany Haddish is our
night school teacher correct you're
clinically down there is no cure for
what you have oh my god Kevin not only
stars from this big-screen comedy he's
also producer and that makes him
Tiffany's boss great superb excellent
good but who's the bigger star here she
had a visit from a girl trip cats yeah
they came here didn't come to see me
didn't care nothing about me Luda came
to see that's does he live around the
corner it's a far cry from Tiffany's
early days as a struggling stand-up
comic living in a car she and Kevin have
been friends since those days and even
loaned her some money back then to help
her out now they're having a good time
on location in Atlanta except Holden
he's working for Joe's barbecue city
what are you doing Joe's barbecue Joe's
barbecue city is my job that I quit high
school for so you can sell ribs I can
sell nose barbecue barbecue barbecue
free barbecue grill this is the grill
for you I call it the Obama come on say
Emma's my ammo the pit bull I'm I'm
selling it to guys like yourself older
men will give it like you did you let it
go oh just gave it or just older man
older men with nothing left except of
barbecue grill like you would be a
perfect custom it would mean everything
of it you keep on saying older men
you're not that okay you're not that old
brother all right follow my sniffing he
also stars with Tracy Morgan a new TV
series the last og that premieres
tomorrow on TBS
you
[Music]